- I just think you've got
to rethink the entire thing.
But to break through the noise,
you, by definition, you have to
do something fundamentally
different than what everybody
else is doing and everybody
else is doing the same thing.
I call it the Taylor Swift Rule.
So I think
Taylor Swift hacked culture.
I think Kanye does it as
well, believe it or not.
Here's what they do.
You scale the unscalable
if you want to break
through the noise today.
So let me explain.
What Taylor Swift's very
good at is she knows that
when people
tweet her and say,
"Taylor, come to my
wedding and sing me a song,"
she actually does it.
Here's why she does it.
The 75 minute allocation of her
time to do something like that
is not ROI positive for Taylor
based on what
she makes for her time.
However, the amplification of
doing something that makes
no sense on paper is where
she gets all her value.
So I get yelled at by all my
smartest CEO friends,
the most fancy gals and guys on
Earth for still answering all
these tweets and emails and
replying one by one on Snapchat
but I know that depth is far
more interesting than width in a
world where the width has just
become completely,
obnoxiously loud and
impossible to break through.
Truth is there are characters
that look like
me running around.
There are people
that understand,
I know not that many,
but you can get somebody
into an honest conversation
because they do not
have aligned interests.
They don't and
they start the
relationship with knowing
each other not at all and that's
the closest on aligned interest
they'll ever be and
is all that happens.
And it breaks so to me let's
just fucking get
it out of the way.
I just think
communication's very valuable.
Like it just works,
it's just nobody does it.
Like really, I mean great
communicators win in life
especially back to why
I married my wife five seconds
into our first date, especially
if you're lucky enough to find
another great communicator
and that's where client
relationships and that's where
business partnerships start.
I just think it's better to know
that it's not a work up front.
(light music)